ich habe dem gefunden 11 ich auch hallo
hier freunde herzlich willkommen zurück
zur nächsten folgt auf minecraft hulu
wir nehmen diese folge gerade im
anschluss an die letzte folge auf was
eventuell keine gute idee ist
das ist als ich bezweifle ist auch sehr
stark ist glaube ich alles andere als
eine gute idee dass wir das grab direkt
im anschluss aufnehmen
aber wenn man es gesagt wir machen jetzt
etwas was nicht
bild s und zwar dort wo das finde ich
aber schon sehr geil also produktivität
wir sind schon gut wie ich glaube diese
map könnten es schaffen durch das
spielen was das denn
danke für das ende über so ja gut
schafft etwas wert wir müssen auch mal
dieses acht herzen obwohl wofür brauchen
eigentlich schief menz ich meine ja für
die karte da darum geht es ja weiter
karte
ja aber das ende haben wir ja und wenn
wir das ende haben wir quasi
durchgespielt naja wir müssen erstmal
die länder drachen besiegen
ich habe mir die archive zuerst mal an
was ist denn jetzt nicht dazu gekommen
adventure timing des cover und bei uns
eher dass keine ahnung wie man das ja
das können wir gar nicht machen wir sind
ja eingesperrt quasi besiegelte ändert
machen
das könnten wir machen das müssen wir
machen oder an die im gast in der hölle
töten obwohl ich bezweifle dass es geht
ich glaube einfach durch den bug geht
das nicht und das mit dem 8 herzen weil
wir stets an ein herz
bei mir steht auf deutsch acht herzen
alter bei mir auf englische die
reinhards of the match aber nicht echt
noch ich mal wieder auf deutsch gibt es
auf englisch gemacht um das mit der
farbe nachzugucken jo auf deutsch täter
komisch skelett mit 50 metern und das
schwein alter wieder mit den anderen
schwein rankommen ich dachte jetzt
endlich mal dass ein schweinegeld moment
haben wir robert ihnen auch ein monument
was wir machen können dass pinkl ja
genau
und dafür brauchen wir diese rose und
dia mehr verloren
verdammt alter damit die tüten nähe oder
ich weiß nicht wer anders kommen wir da
nicht ran
ich packe diejenigen sachen war erst mal
hier in die kiste nee nicht schießen wir
so keine ahnung muss nicht sein
ja eventuell muss es sein weil wir das
anders nicht hinkommen wo nicht du warst
du machen möchtest junger padova ich
weiß auch nicht was was die zuschauer am
besten wäre es wenn wir euch jetzt
fragen aber da wir diese folge im voraus
halt wieder aufnehmen ich weiß nicht wir
haben die sicher alles so also es bringt
an sich kein nachteil
also werden wir jetzt diese rose quasi
haben und dann kriegen wir daraus dass
pinkl tief mit haben wir einerseits die
skifans durch und die rose gut meint er
die momente und die rose ist halt
wirklich durch eine explosion kaputt
gegangen ja mehr oder weniger durch das
wasser ist die weg getrieben und dann
durch eine explosion durch den körper
verdammt das ist eine blöde situation ja
was macht man da was machen
ich hatte es mir kannste net die könnten
mal ganz kurz spontan bei twitter posten
bei twitter fragen
das könnte mehr machen weil das gerade
live dabei ist mal ganz kurz machen
kannst du machen was man ganz kurz was
mich auch wundert ihr ich habe noch kein
skelett gesehen außerhalb der world
water
ich auch nicht ich weiß nicht wie das
machen sollen das müssen wir wohl
wirklich in der schlucht unten machen
aber angeblich geht es ja nur in die
breite
aber als tipp wurde angezeigt think
outside the box also dass man irgendwie
was außerhalb werden soll
aber das kommt einfach nicht immer kann
er die fackeln oben wegnehmen und dann
nochmal gucken da brauch ich mir ein tor
mehr als mache ich das mache ich die
zeit sprengte als trepte 2 zurück keaton
um die monumente zu vollenden
oder seid ihr dagegen wenn ihr jetzt bei
twitter dabei werdet könnt ihr jetzt
gerade am hart 22 um 16 uhr mitbestimmen
aber ich schaue mal ganz kurz hier was
die leute schreiben
in der zwischenzeit was sollte ich denn
noch machen ich wollte ja ach so ich
wollte kurz die kühe hier nochmal pan
und einmal wieder den clown fisch
benutzen um die zu töten
gott ist es unsere kisten sortierung
wieder komplett am arsch
das war auch noch die wertvollen truhe
dia gesprengt hat ja angeles für diese
schau bringt
in der vorletzten kiste habe ich gerade
einfach diesem clown fisch gefunden wir
haben auch keinen leser wo hat war zu
viel für die tränke und nähe
die retter warten dafür müssen wir diese
scheiß hölle alter das stellen wir fünf
mal wo ich hab viel leder bekommen er
das ist echt ein guter tipp gewesen
danken angegangen gespickten nachher
aber nicht noch mehr kühe töten
hast du trotzdem nicht rausgekommen ich
bevölkerung so viel leder heißt wieder
ordentlich bücher dann nehme ich mal
ganz kurz hier die seiten wo haben wir
die ideen da sind die daten den sattel
haben
wir haben halt kein schwein so viele
bücher es brauche ich noch ein bisschen
gerätschaften das noch holz baualter wir
brauchen echten schein
ich glaube das schwein bekommt man
wirklich durch dieses pinkl weil
wildschweine ist ja auch pink ja das
könnte ich ja obwohl doch das kann
wirklich sein sohn noch ein bücherregal
ich schaue mal eben bei twitter was da
so rein kommt als antworten
wer also das was man gezeigt wird ist
macht das ja ich bin dafür bieten er
macht bitte also bis jetzt absolute
mehrheit
wie soll ich dieses 9
doch wie soll ich das da auch kommen
macht die carl orff kenne ich dachte hey
was machst du alter wie sich jetzt auf
kreativ man kann es mir mal ganz kurz
weiterhelfen kann ich machen
wie soll ich das bücherregal ihr
anbringen an sich ist das egal
hauptsache der abstand stimmt geht das
land stellen warte ich bin bei dir
wenn man die rose naja da geht so
ziemlich die rose die können jetzt nicht
in einen roten farbstoff dann packt er
den roten farbstoff auf das alle mit
einem knochen da rein
dann haben wir rosa farbstoff juli und
jetzt wir haben nur einen gebranntem ton
wir brauchen noch mehr clay wie noch
mehr ja der ganzen anderen habe ich
dafür dass andere gebraucht wir brauchen
nicht noch mehr
doch wer braucht noch mehr hier ist noch
ein stück ton drin ja ein stück wir
brauchen ton alltag ton so und sohn
müssen ton suchen und wir brauchen etwa
zehn für den trank ton wo bekommen wir
toni aus der höhle
ja gut dann gehe ich noch mal runter ja
ich sagte spitzer gast eine spitzhacke
erwarteten noch reisen berufen oder
jetzt eisen ist auch schon wieder weg
meine also ein offiziell waren die
anderes total am arsch verdammt eisen
wurden die reisen des eisen wird in die
luft gesprengt oder gar keine wertvollen
tue mir wird ganz einfach nur noch alles
irgendwie da rein
das eisen hast du ja das ist echt ein
bisschen doof gerade ich nehme dieses
rückstoß schwert besser auch mama mit
haben wir stäbe noch holz haben wir
irgendwo noch an und versteht diese
letzte folge hat mich echt so
mitgenommen ja und mich auch dass
verdächtigen wie gestorben sind
unsere teams kämpfen mussten wie oft ich
mich auch uns dann gesagt dann dieser
rückschlag durch den körper in unserer
base aber haben auch die spitzhacke
glück 1 comeback denkt er hier muss doch
wohl irgendwo noch klar sein wir haben
immer nur diesen gefärbten ton aber
daraus kann man ja nicht irgendwie was
zurück machen wenn wir nur so komische
sachen wo findet man ton in ton auf
jeden fall aber tun haben wir keine mehr
richtig da es ein clay drin
er soll ich mal versuchen dass die
ammann schon zu verzaubern
jor könnte es zu machen wir können jetzt
schon bis auf level 13 gehen
das ist band 2 neben nicht wir brauchen
schärfe 2 wäre schon ganz gut aber dafür
wollen wir mehr bücherregal und dafür
brauchen wir mehr kühe
obwohl ich kann aber welche von unseren
pilz kühner oben auch töten mit dem
clown fisch stimmt das kann ich machen
wir haben hier noch erfahrungs
fläschchen also eine erfahrung scheitert
es wahrscheinlich nicht
ja ich nehme jetzt einfach mal hier noch
der schweiz sind partner oben paar und
immer den clown fisch mit ach so die
sonne wandert direkt mit dem himmlischen
hey warum ist das so grell draußen da
ist ne kuh hatte dies direkt tod einfach
direkt vier leder oder sind auch noch
ein paar dran du bist du dich töten
wollte ich weiß schon was du meinst mit
dem claim also langsam komme ich
dahinter wie mit dem er wirklich gar
nichts mehr davon
ja das ist damals nichts geht man raus
ich möchte raus sagt also ich hab schon
wieder sechs lädt eine kleine baby co
ich meine wieder sechs leder vor allem
and raum eventuell kleine da war gar nix
war ja nur stein element raum
ja es stimmt aber wirklich nichts aber
da das ist daran hat sechs bücher
und aus diesen sechs büchern mache ich
jetzt mit holz weil bücherregale also
wie soll ich die anordnung dass das
stimmt von vom abstand wie kein anderer
staat ausmachen
also kannst immer daneben stellen okay
gut oder auch darauf wie du möchtest
darauf ist auch cool wir können jetzt
bis level 14 aber das ist man keine
ahnung hat und ich habe mich verlaufen
nagari immer noch bahn ekelhaft dass das
denn jetzt ihr schwert das war noch da
also das habe ich eine truhe gepackt 100
prozent fertig ich kann es dir schwer
ein mann watet park magazin noch dazu
wenn ich jetzt wüsste wo die reise
dieser scheiß master wir können wirklich
nur bis baden gehen
wir brauchen ja du musst ein paar mal
öfters reinlegen
das schwert wir raus sondern wir waren
das höchste ist bahn zwei yamaha nötig
sogar 14 level was hat er was mit glück
zu tun ob man gerade bahn bekommt der
schärfe man kann das tun haben natürlich
das irgendwie dem kanal und so wie es
aussieht nicht auch verdammte kacke was
können wir denn jetzt noch machen wir
können wir gibt das einzige was machen
können ist immer mehr bücherregale darum
umbauen weil das kann nicht ziel sein
dann könnte man die hölle aber wir
könnten uns an dem entfachen probieren
na ja also wir brauchen dafür beiden
bogen viele pfeile müssen wir schauen
wie viele wieder insgesamt anfallen
dann brauchen wir beide eine gute
rüstung ich habe also eine die rüstung
haben wir ja dann benötigen wir dafür
eventuell noch lebens tränke und nahrung
lebens tränke haben wir nahrung haben
wir auch genug durch die suppen
ich glaube anfang märz japan und an der
rüstung
da sind halt extrem fia wir brauchen
vielleicht kürbissamen kürbisse
endermann kürbisse stimmt warum sie nie
haben wir da eigentlich ihr übernommen
ich suche einfach weiter nach leben hier
muss doch irgendwo war man hier den
zombies bonn ab und auch gerne reisen
abbauen
eisern für die rüstung also ja stimmt
ich werde jetzt mal ein paar komische
leute
es kann doch nicht sein doch wenig leben
wir brauchen nicht viel nur ganz wenig
ich hab dem gefundenen herrlich ja aber
ich weiß nicht wie viel das sieht sehr
wenig aus kaum einer schaufel ab und
damit glück ich bin hier bei dir also
ein blog leben
was machen wir hier hast du deinen
kleinen fisch dabei der plünderung
keinen job bekommt er mal glück ich
glaube nur wählen einfach so mit ja vier
stück haben den anfang einer wir
brauchen jetzt noch warten wir brauchen
noch sieben von diesen blöcken von
diesen claim blöcken leben nehmen
clem clempson und leben club kreml
das ist doch so traurig dass es an dem
leben ich bereue es auch gerade dass wir
am anfang also wir lernen durch jede
karte wirklich immer dazu am anfang die
liste wird hat mitleid hat die nächste
wahl in den wasser tempeln alter immer
so rum schwimm und so und ich gehe mal
hier nochmal eine etage unter das wird
schon hart das wird sehr haarig und war
ich ja sagen es wird hart ich okay ist
hier nicht noch irgendwie was aber unter
diesen teilen es auch nie leben da sind
immer nur so blöcke er teilweise schräg
dass seine wänden also ich habe ja eben
auch einfach mal die wand aufgebaut und
zack da war leben jetzt noch ein zombie
ich hab noch gar kein leben gefunden
ich bin schlecht hey ich brauche mal das
wasser ab wenn ich es mir erlauben darf
meine ich dass ich irgendwie im worunter
schwimmst du den ball ab zieht es wenn
wir noch gar nicht gewesen
euro das einfach mal creeper
ihr euch ab eingang gefunden 9
java jedoch nicht meisterschafts
erlernten lempe das schön gewesen ist
leben klar ist dass ihr versprochen
wir brauchen clem clempson war ich doch
schwerer job und er haut direkt mit dem
schwert denn irgendwann böse mensch
gewesen weil er ja auch ich hab keine
fackeln mehr total böser mensch komme
wir brauchen michael klemm ja wie wir
nochmal weiter runter wo ist da der
aufzug nach unten kann einfach irgendein
loch und auf einmal kommt er in silber
fischen silberfisch aber der zwang oder
ist hier wahrscheinlich auch bald der
dungeon raum eng vun deene der steckt
hier bestimmt oder ich bin mir nicht
sicher ist kann auch sein dass es so
einfach immer mal so treu blöcke sind
oder kommt einfach mal sonst borner
alter inmitten der wandstärke einfach
mal sonst bonner grad drin
hätte ich eine fackel will ich jetzt
eine fackel setzen leute aber tut mir
leid aber wir müssen auch die folge ein
gestellter beenden eine alte regel
schafft terrorist ins bonner ich hab ihn
ganz abgebaut
aber man ist das ekelhaft wir brauchen
und leben jetzt durchstreifen hier diese
cup holen
hier sind auch wieder neues banner ist
das denn
deshalb ins bonner ich habe leben
gefunden werde ich auch
wieder ich auch also ich habe jetzt vier
noch mal vergibt die gibt die mir ich
habe acht vielleicht stirbt da ich sehe
schon kommen hier hast du vier gerst man
muss ja heute zeitweise auch mal haben
wir brauchen noch fünf blöcke jetzt fünf
leben blöcke aber ich würde sagen diese
reise diese suche nach dem leben blöcken
geht in der nächsten folge weiter aber
es ist ja schön dass wir wenigstens
überhaupt noch ein paar finden mit der
rein gar keine messe wie verpackt haben
irgendwie hoffentlich finden wir noch
ein paar drückt uns die daumen durch den
daumen hoch oder willi fragen wir uns
morgen in der nächsten folge wieder auf
gomez kanal und an kühlmittel mit